c'est que le président buffet pour
suivre donc ça ne modifie en rien
l'organisation que nous nous avions
envisagé merci d'abord d'être venu
quelques remarques préalables avant
qu'on rentre dans les autres rapports et
les propositions que nous avons souhaité
formuler d'abord sur là où nous en
sommes à ce stade les deux commissions
vous le savez se sont saisis très
rapidement président plus faire ils se
sont saisis très rapidement
dès le mercredi en auditionnant les deux
délai mercredi qui a suivi de la finale
de la chambre seule singh en
démissionnant les deux ministres et nous
avons poursuivi ses auditions à travers
une série d'auditions nous en sommes à
la remise de la présentation du rapport
qui a été voté ce matin et je le
souligne à l'unanimité des membres des
deux commissions la commission des lois
et la commission de de la culture ça
clôt donc la phase de travail que nous
avions
engagé
avec l'audition des deux ministres nous
avons tenu dans ce rapport à faire une
analyse précise et détaillée des
dysfonctionnement de l'ensemble des
dysfonctionnements d'établir des
responsables responsabilités des uns et
des autres mais aussi de faire des
propositions pour éviter que ces
événements ne se reproduisent
alors nous allons décrire dans quelques
minutes les dysfonctionnements je
voudrais dire concernant l'analyse que
nous avons de ce dysfonctionnement c'est
un enchaînement de dysfonctionnements
qui se sont produits dans un cadre
administratif
et décisionnaires assez flou dans lequel
finalement personne ne s'est vraiment
senti responsable et pour le dire avec
une image sportive en fait chacun était
dans son couloir sans qu'il y ait une
vraie coordination et sans qu'il y ait
une autorité qu'ils fassent preuve d'un
esprit clairvoyant assurant la
coordination et le bon fonctionnement de
l'ensemble et surtout qu'ils prennent
les arbitrages nécessaires ces
dysfonctionnements ils ont eu lieu comme
vous le allez l'entendre dans quelques
minutes à toutes les étapes de de cet
événement c'est à dire bien sûr pendant
l'exécution mais aussi en amont dans la
préparation il ya eu des défaillances
lors de la préparation et après
l'événement avec là aussi une série de
dysfonctionnements qui n'aurait pas dû
se produire pour que
nous soyons très clairs dans la
philosophie qui a fait l'état d'esprit
qui est le nôtre et qui était partagé
par l'ensemble des membres des deux
commissions cet événement ces événements
du stade de france doivent être un coup
de semonce par rapport à la préparation
des deux grands événements que sont la
coupe du monde de rugby l'année
prochaine et les jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 il ne s'agit en
aucun cas de remettre en cause
l'existence de ces deux événements nous
sommes les uns et les autres attaché à
la tenue de ces événements est fier que
ces deux événements et lieux sur notre
territoire national néanmoins la gravité
de ce qui s'est passé le au stade de
france montre qu' il y a encore de
nombreux réglages et de nombreux décide
nombreuses décisions à prendre pour
faire en sorte que ces dysfonctionne ces
incidents ne se reproduisent pas enfin
dernière remarque préalable que je
voudrais formuler c'est que à ce jour
les plus hautes autorités de l'état ne
se sont pas exprimés sur les événements
et je crois qu'il est utile et
nécessaire
que il le fasse pour que nous sachions
quel sont les analyses de ces événements
et quels sont les enseignements qu'ils
en tirent en tout cas côté sénat je
crois que l'on peut dire que le travail
que nous avons fait conjointement avec
les deux commissions a permis
progressivement et au fil et à mesure
des auditions que la vérité apparaisse
c'est qu'elle se fasse dans l'esprit de
travail de notre maison c'est à dire en
toute transparence
et aujourd'hui nous avons une vision
plus claire de ce qui s'est passé ce sur
quoi nous allons revenir en identifiant
les principaux
les principaux dysfonctionnements et en
faisant c'est extrêmement important à
nos yeux d'être aussi dans une démarche
positive et de proposition et en faisant
des recommandations premières grandes
causes premier grande série de
dysfonctionnements la gestion de la
billetterie qui s'est révélée inadaptée
les travaux menés ont permis d'établir
que la gestion de la billetterie par
l'uefa a était inadapté certes
l'émission de billets sous format papier
ne constituait pas en elle-même une
situation exceptionnelle et cette
possibilité était conforme à la
réglementation ceci étant dit il était
connu que le recours à ce type de billet
aurait pour conséquence une
multiplication des faux billets or
l'uefa ne semble pas avoir mis en place
de dispositif particulier pour
identifier l'ampleur de ce problème en
amont alors que le nombre de faux
billets a été dix fois supérieures aux
moyennes observées habituellement vous
connaissez le chiffre mais je le répète
je vous rappelle pardon 2471 faux
billets scanner dont plus de 1600 dans
le secteur sud soyons clairs là dessus
si la fosse billetterie a participé à
perturber le déroulement des événements
elle ne peut en aucun cas être
considérés comme la cause unique ni même
la cause principale par ailleurs en
exigeant la mise en place d'un contrôle
de la validité des billets au niveau des
points de près filtrage de sécurité dans
le cadre du dispositif anti terroriste
l'uefa involontairement participé au
blocage des points de contrôle compte
tenu notamment du nombre plus important
que d'habitude de personne dépourvue de
billet je crois que le président du fer
reviendra sur cet aspect là à noter
également l'insuffisance dispositif de
traitement des litiges concernant la
billetterie qui a mené les personnes et
conduites à stationner devant les points
de filtrage ainsi que la formation
défaillante des stadiers qui ont semblé
très vite dépassés par la situation
enfin les modalités de vérification des
billets ont également fait débat
l'utilisation des stylos pour marquer
les billets le dispositif de
vérification des billets électroniques
n'ayant pas été considérées comme
suffisamment pratique dans ces
conditions notre première recommandation
est de rendre obligatoire le recours à
des billets à facile hein falsifiable
c'est à dire tronic avec des dispositifs
de contrôle fiable pour les compétitions
de football aux enjeux les plus
importants on peut penser bien sûr
rencontres internationales mais aussi au
derby lors du chan pendant le
championnat de france et de prévoir
systématiquement un service de règlement
des litiges de billetterie ainsi qu'un
dispositif des aides pour les personnes
ne pouvant recourir à ce type de billets
afin de pouvoir résoudre les difficultés
en temps réel nous proposons c'est notre
recommandation numéro 2 d'exiger des
organisateurs qu'il informe en temps
réel par mail par sms par un messagerie
les détenteurs de billets des modalités
d'accès au stade de france des
événements imprévus et des modifications
décidées par les autorités lorsque
surviennent des difficultés enfin nous
estimons nécessaire une meilleure
formation des stadiers une articulation
entre les stadiers les forces de l'ordre
c'est notre recommandation numéro 3
deuxième grande cause des
dysfonctionnements le plan de mobilité
des supporters qui a été à plusieurs
moments prise en défaut la préparation
du plan de mobilité des supporters
relevait principalement de la compétence
de la fédération française de football
afin de prendre en charge les supporters
depuis les frontières jusqu aux abords
du stade ce plan de mobilité a rencontré
de difficultés majeures vous les
connaissez le report des voyageurs du
rer d sur le rer b et l'absence de voies
de délestage à la sortie de la gare du
rer d dont les effets se sont cumulées
pour aboutir à une situation de crise
alors que les prévisions concernant la
grève du rer b prévoyaient un maintien
du service à 80% de ses capacités
la fédération française soutient que les
déports de la ligne b et la ligne d ont
été aggravées la ligne b à la ligne
départ dont été aggravée par des
messages diffusés dans les gares par les
transporteurs dans l'après-midi du 28
mai indiquant de ne pas utiliser la
ligne b ces annonces qui n'était pas
prévue par le plan de mobilité mais
semble avoir été validée lors d'une
réunion qui s'est tenue la veille du
match avec la préfecture de police et
les transporteurs publics sans la
fédération a évidemment largement
perturbé l'arrivée des spectateurs
une parenthèse mais est importante saül
illustre évidemment la
difficulté des changes entre les
différents acteurs avec les effets tout
à fait préjudiciable que ça a eu pour
conséquence le 28 mai la suppression de
l'interconnexion à la gare du nord à
constituer une difficulté supplémentaire
dissuadant nombre de supporteurs de
liverpool de poursuivre leur trajet avec
le rer b et favorisant les reports sur
la ligne d au delà de ce qui était prévu
est nécessaire autre
défaillance sur lequel aussi présents du
feu reviendra le démontage à la demande
de la direction de l'ordre public et de
la circulation de la préfecture de
police le 23 mai soit quelques jours
avant l'événement la signalétique
installé par la fédération française à
la sortie de la gare du rer d du stade
de france pour baliser un cheminement de
délestage vers la gare du rer b à
constituer la seconde difficulté majeure
qui a rendu très difficile la gestion de
la crise lorsque l'engorgement du
cheminement au point de pris filtrage
est intervenue la seule solution
possible à ce moment là a été de la
levée du dispositif de contrôle avec les
effets que nous connaissons et l'entrée
de très nombreux délinquants dans le
périmètre restreint nous pensons que le
plan de mobilité des supporters auraient
dû mieux prendre en compte les aléas
notamment les grèves et les reports de
flux que ça engendre et prévoir des
plans alternatifs pour organiser des
reports comme cela a été indiqué lors
des auditions si le délai des trois mois
a permis d'organiser l'événement
correctement il n'a pas permis de
travailler suffisamment les différents
scénarios de crise dans ces conditions
nous recommandons que les différents
acteurs concernés définissent
conjointement un plan de mobilité des
supporteurs en prévoyant ce qu'il semble
ne pas avoir été le cas les différents
scénarios de crise nécessaire nous
insistons par ailleurs sur la nécessité
d'organiser une communication en temps
réel et efficace sur les flux de
supporters entre la fédération la
préfecture de police et les opérateurs
de transport en commun est de veiller
une mise en oeuvre conjointe des
décisions imposées par les événements
imprévus c'est notre roman cas de
recommandation numéro 4 nous préconisons
ensuite que le plan de mobilité des
supporters organise les voies d'accès au
stade en prévoyant systématiquement les
cheminements de délestage suffisent en
ainsi que des voies d'évacuation pour
les personnes rencontrant des
difficultés c'est notre cinquième
recommandations nous estimons riom par
ailleurs utile d'améliorer
l'attractivité des abords du stade de
france afin d'inciter les spectateurs à
venir plus tôt et à repartir plus tard
afin de mieux réguler les flux d'entrée
et de sortie vers les transports c'est
la recommandation numéro 6 plus
généralement nous demandons un
rétablissement des effectifs d'agents
publics dédiés à la circulation des flux
piétons et automobile autour du stade je
vous rappelle qu'il ya quelques années
il y avait 90 agents de police qui
étaient affectés à cette mission le soir
de la finale de la champions league ils
n'étaient qu'une dizaine
troisième cause de dysfonctionnement une
prise en compte des supporters
insuffisantes les auditions des
associations de supporters que nous
avons menées auquel vous avez pu
assister ont mis en évidence une
organisation de la sécurité du match
fondée sur une vision vision dates et
des supporteurs britanniques en voyant
hooligans des années 80 les responsables
publics ont ainsi été presque
exclusivement attaché à gérer sous
l'angle du maintien de l'ordre les
supporteurs anglais sans billet qui ont
comme habitude on le sait de venir
soutenir leur équipe en grand nombre les
organisateurs se sont ainsi privés des
moyens qui permettent d'acheminer les
plus de spectateurs au stade ou de les
divertir aux alentours du stade où les
endroits sécurisés en ville le président
du fait là aussi il reviendra sur sept
points là de manière plus générale
accueille dans un cadre festif des
supporters a été négligée heureusement
les fans zones ont été installées loin
du stade malheureusement et
l'interdiction de l'alcool à partir de
18 heures aux alentours du stade a
contribué à leur arrivée tardive sur le
stade enfin l'accueil des supporters
nécessite également de veiller à ce que
leurs conditions de retour après le
match soit bonne les supporters
espagnols vous le savez se sont plaints
que le passage sur une passe elle assez
étroites franchissant le canal sans
personne pour réguler les flux et le
manque d'éclairage public alors que le
sol était jonché de bouteilles cassées
tout ceci laisse à penser que
l'expérience spectateur n'a pas été
prise en compte par les organisateurs de
l'événement ou souhaitons donc que le
regard des autorités publiques
françaises sur les supporters évolué et
que soit créé les conditions d'un
dialogue permanent afin de faire des
leurs représentants des partenaires dans
le cadre de la préparation du
déroulement des grands événements le
dialogue avec les supporters doit
permettre de mieux partager les
informations de les rendre plus
efficaces
les rendre plus efficaces ces
dispositifs mis en place c'est une
recommandation forte que nous formulons
je cède la parole au président buffet
pour les recommandations suivantes
merci quelques observations fera là
peut-être sur la situation que nous
avons et puis finalement établie à 2
rappelez peut-être les conditions mais
vous le savez tous toutes et tous ce
match s'est déroulé dans des conditions
particulières puisque initialement il
était prévu à saint pétersbourg s'est
malheureusement raison des évènements
entre l'ukraine et la russie que le 24
février le président de la république
avait répondu favorablement
à la sollicitation de l'uefa de tenir le
match à paris et a donc engagé de
soutien des pouvoirs publics pour
l'organisation du match rappelle que
l'uefa et son mandataire la fédération
française de football ont donc travaillé
avec le soutien du délégué
interministériel aux grands événements
sportifs et des préfectures et
singulièrement pour la région parisienne
la préfecture de police
le soir du match de multiples incidents
ont mis à mal le dispositif de sécurité
mis en place
le début du match a été je rappelle
retardé d'une demi-heure
la raison donnée a été l'arrivée tardive
des supporters de liverpool
cette première imputation apparu
d'emblée comme une forme d'injustice par
les supporters dont 2700 étaient munis
de billets valables lesquels n'ont pas
pu assister au match lui même
ça car ce n'était pas l'arrivée tardive
aurait été qui a causé des difficultés
mais l'impossibilité d'entrer dans le
stade qu'il faisait qu'il n'était pas en
tribunes au moment où le match a débuté
en dehors du stade en effet les
supporters avaient été retenus au point
de près filtrage mis en place dans le
prolongement de la sortie du rer b une
masse de l'ordre de 10 à 15000 personnes
s'étant constitué et suscitant un risque
d'écrasement une fois ce dispositif
lever la foule a pu s'approcher des
tourniquets d'entrée mais certains
proches des grilles du stade ont alors
été exposés aux gaz lacrymogènes
l'ensemble de ce parcours était ponctuée
par les agressions de la part de
délinquants nombreux et violents tout
ceci documenté par de nombreuses vidéos
bien sûr circulant sur les réseaux
sociaux a naturellement terni l'image de
la france or
ce sont les supporters de clubs anglais
qui ont été présentés comme des
principaux fautifs des incidents
d'emblée puis devant nos commissions
c'est en dépit des défauts de plus en
plus saillant dans l'organisation mise
en place qui sont un peu que sont
apparus qui que sont apparus au fil de
nos travaux se souhaite faire un premier
constat
c'est enfin nous souhaitons plutôt pas
long feu après constat c'est que ce
n'est que qu'avec l' annonce des
auditions par la commission par les
commissions sénatoriales ce nous nous
sommes deux commissions que les
ministres concernés ont émis des regrets
sur l'expérience gâcher je cite des
spectateurs munis de billets mais
n'ayant pas pu assister au match tout
match qui sont quand même 2700 je le
disais puis au cours de nos auditions
sont venues des regrets du préfet de
police pour les personnes de bonne foi
exposés aux gaz lacrymogènes enfin le
miz de l'intérieur suite à la
présentation des premiers constats que
nous avions fait à l'issue des auditions
à présenter finalement ses excuses aux
supporters ayant subi la mauvaise
gestion de l'événement revenons-en sur
le point particulier
le 28 mai la sécurité des supporters et
la protection des biens n'ont pas été
assurées de manière suffisante le préfet
de police lors de son audition a estimé
que les scènes de chaos liés à la
délinquance était dû à la nécessité de
lever le filtrage permettant à 300 à 400
individus je le cite
indésirables sur le site toujours de
s'introduire sur le parvis le dispositif
ne présentant plus l'étanchéité
suffisante ni la capacité dissuasive
nécessaires pour empêcher ces vols je le
cite encore mais ainsi qu'on a notamment
témoigné le maire de la métropole de
liverpool les actes de délinquance ont
en réalité commencé en amont du film
rage les caméras de surveillance ont
même permis à certaines personnes
présentes présente dans le pc de
sécurité du stade de constater l'action
des pickpockets et autres voleurs à la
tire ans les effectifs de sécurité
présent très majoritairement dédié aux
dispositifs anti terroristes n'ont pu
intervenir pour mettre fin à ces actes
une fois les délinquants présents sur le
parvis leur évacuation du stade nature
leur évacuation a été particulièrement
difficile et lente n'intervenant
qu'après le début du match et ne faisons
que repousser les délinquants à la
périphérie du stade où la délinquance
s'est poursuivie après le match ceci est
d'autant plus inacceptable que la
présence de ceux ci étaient prévisibles
dans les jours précédant l'événement le
match de football les personnels du
stade de france et le maire de saint
denis ont fait part d'une effervescence
inhabituelle autour de l'enceinte dans
la tente du match ces observations n'ont
cependant pas conduit semble-t-il à une
alerte de la part du renseignement
territoriales
les effectifs destinés à lutter contre
la délinquance était donc sous
dimensionné et n'ont pas été abordés de
manière suffisante malgré les multiples
intrusions et vols à compter de la mi
journée du 28 mai effectivement les
faits de délinquance ont été constatés à
partir de midi puis ensuite à 15 heures
et ensuite pro reste le rapport dudit
geste fait état de 209 effectifs de
police déployés autour du stade pour
lutter contre la criminalité le 28 mai
soit 47 personnes de plus que lors de la
finale de la coupe de france le 7 mai
al'inverse
lors du match france danemark du 2 juin
ces 650 effectifs de police soit plus de
trois fois plus soit plus de trois fois
plus d'agents qui avaient été mobilisés
pour lutter contre la délinquance c'est
donc seulement suite aux incidents que
la mesure réelle de la délinquance a été
prise en compte à ceci s'ajoute un
élément qui nous paraît essentiel
nous savons que la querelle des chiffres
a beaucoup occupé les premiers temps de
nos auditions suite aux affirmations du
préfet de police et du ministre sur les
trente six mille personnes venues sans
titre ou avec de faux titres au stade
mais ce nombre dans le préfet de police
nous a dit qu'il pouvait tout aussi bien
être de 24000 n'ont en réalité pas
d'importance n'a pas l'importance plutôt
que la communication des poids public a
bien voulu nous prêter le dispositif mis
en place en réalité était débordé sur un
point très précis le pré filtrage situer
dans la continuité de la sortie du rer b
il n'a fallu que 10000 à 15000 personnes
pour rendre ce prêt filtrage intenable
quand bien même il n'y aurait pas eu de
supporters il y aurait eu pardon plus de
supporters que deux places dans le stade
la situation aurait pu être la même
cause et le même chaos et conduire à des
drames que nous avons par chance éviter
cet échec tient donc ou décision prise
par la préfecture de police
conçu pour prévenir des attaques
terroristes
le dispositif de pré filtrage mises en
place par la préfecture de police a été
combiné un contrôle de validité des
billets d par les stadiers ceci a créé
un goulot d'étranglement
l'espace disponible était réduit à 4 ou
5 mètres de large par la présence de
véhicules destinés à faire obstruction
voiture bélier
notons d'abord que le préfet michel
cadot dans son rapport remis à la
première ministre a pointé le manque de
fondement juridique de la combinaison
d'un dispositif anti terroriste et d'un
contrôle des titres d'accès par les
organisateurs pour défendre ce choix le
préfet de police a fait porter la
responsabilité de la saturation sur le
nombre de supporters de l'équipe de
liverpool venus avec des billets facile
falsifiés pardon ou tentant de
s'approcher du stade sans billet ceux ci
auraient saturé dit il le prêt contrôle
lequel a fait apparaître jusqu'à 70 %
d'erreurs puis crée l'encombrement de
personnes présentes dans l'accès aux
points de filtrage
mais l'accord donné à la mise en place
d'un contrôle de validité des billets au
niveau du prêt filtrage qui n'avait été
essayé qu'une seule fois auparavant et
n'avait pas donné pleinement satisfait
on était d'emblée inopportun
il a conduit tant à négliger le risque
de délinquance sur le parvis entourant
le stade puisque des indésirables des
mini du billet n'aurait pas dû pouvoir y
accéder qu'à ralentir le flot entrants
des personnes de plus la préfecture n'a
pas prévu un moyen d'évacuer les
personnes refoulées et qu'ils ne
pouvaient reculer du fait de
l'étroitesse de l'accès et de la foule
massée dans la tente du passage à ce
défaut premier dans la conception
dispositif s'ajoute la gestion du flux
des personnes la sncf a indiqué avoir
transporté le jour du match 12 mille
personnes de plus que pour d'autres
événements de ce type mais c'est moins
ce surnombre en soi que le déséquilibre
entre la gestion des flux venant des
deux lignes de rer qui a été source de
cette difficulté en effet
l'infrastructure du stade de france peut
accueillir un flot de près de cent mille
personnes pour certains événements de
grands stades nous avions a dit enfin
les organes les dirigeants du grand
stade nous avions indiqué que pour le
concert d'indochine il y avait cent dix
mille personnes dans le stade
118 personnes lui ce n'est sur la
pelouse est utilisé évidemment le
surnombre établie par la sncf aux
sorties les plus proches des tribunes
destiné aux supporters du club de
liverpool était donc inhabituel c'est
vrai mais disproportionnée par rapport
aux accès du stade
mais pas disproportionné mais pas
disproportionné par rapport aux accès du
stade mais dès lors que s'était
constitué un encombrement de 10 à 15000
personnes selon l'estimation du préfet
de police le préfet le trajet risquait
de conduire un risque d'écrasement ce
seuil de saturation semble relativement
bas quand on regarde des flux du flux
normal du rer d pour un match de ce type
qu'au regard du report lié à la grève de
la ligne rer b il y est également de la
part de nos autorités
un manque de réactivité les flux des
passagers en provenance de chacune des
lignes horaires étaient communiqué
toutes les demi heures à partir de 18h05
par la sncf au poste de commandement du
stade d'emblée et surtout à partir de
18h30 l'importante écarts de
fréquentation entre la ligne d et la
ligne b était connu mais cette situation
n'a suscité aucune réelle action rapide
de réorientation des flux ni de la part
des transporteurs qui ont indiqué ne pas
avoir été sollicité pour ce faire ni des
organisateurs ou encore de la préfecture
de police qui a mis en oeuvre cette
réorientation seulement à
19h18 trop tard en pratique pour
permettre un maintien du dispositif de
pré filtrage la pression se constituait
déjà depuis près d'une heure les
supporters venus au stade de france et
se présentant au point de près filtrage
prévu par le prolongement des airs de la
ligne du rer d on fait face à deux
risques le premier était le risque
d'écrasement du fait du blocage du prêt
filtrage des blocs du local près vitrage
le second était celui de subir les
effets du gazage al'approche des grilles
du stade face à ces risques le préfet de
police a d'abord pris la décision de
lever temporairement le pré filtrage un
19h39 puis assumer le recours aux gaz
lacrymogènes pour faire reculer les
personnes proches des grilles du stade
ce second choix découle et non de la
nécessité de protéger les personnes mais
d'abord d'éviter la chute des grilles et
l'envahissement du stade tu aurais eu
incontestablement bien sûr des
conséquences dramatiques les décisions
prises si elles ont peut-être évité un
drame ou l'annulation du match sont la
conséquence directe des défaut
d'anticipation et ont été la cause
d'incidents qui ont choqué l'opinion
publique nationale et internationale et
probablement dernier à cette occasion
l'image de la france nous sommes
rattrapés depuis les autres événements
qui se sont tenues la décision devait
profite rage à créer un espace sur le
parvis du stade dans lequel ont pu
s'engouffrer alors les délinquants qui
ont agressé les supporters il a
rapproché ce qu'ils cherchaient à
s'introduire illégalement dans le stade
de leurs objectifs ou de leurs objectifs
face aux risques d'intrusion sont
bientôt terminées les forces de sécurité
ont eu recours aux gaz lacrymogènes pour
faire reculer la foule cette méthode qui
affecte les personnes présentes au delà
de celles directement visé a été battu
apparu paru particulièrement agressive
aux supporters venant de pays où elle
n'est pas pratique et elle a contribué
incontestablement aux sentiments des
supporters d'avoir été exposé un usage
excessif de la force voire à d'autres
événements de violence
important les préfètes police a
cependant d'autant plus de 6000 euros qu
au gaz lacrymogène qui la considérait
que c'était le seul moyen à disposition
des forces de sécurité pour faire
reculer la foule à moins de la charge et
la question d'ailleurs de l' usage de
gaz lacrymogènes montre la contradiction
parmi les responsables des forces de
sécurité intérieure nos recommandations
tous les cas pour ce qui concerne la
partie sécurité sont les suivants vous
avez peut-être le document qu'on vous a
remis en tous les cas je le souhaite le
document la recommandation numéro 7 qui
s'adresse à l'uefa la préfecture de
police consiste à séparer les points de
contrôle de validité des billets des
points de près filtrage mises en place
dans le cadre de la prévention du
terrorisme
la recommandation numéro 8 qui s'adresse
aux ministères de l'intérieur et de
définir une doctrine d'emploi du gaz
lacrymogène par les agents des forces de
sécurité qui préviennent l'exposition de
personnes ne présentant pas pour eux un
danger immédiat la recommandation numéro
9 qui ça va c'est la préfecture de
police et le cas échéant à la ville de
saint denis qui est de rétablir les
effectifs d'agents publics dédiés à la
circulation des flux piétons et
automobile autour du stade la
recommandation numéro 10 à la préfecture
de police et de privilégiés en matière
de gestion des foules le pré
positionnement de moyens dissuadant tout
débordement on pense en particulier aux
unités équestre notamment qui ont un
effet sécurisant extrêmement fort la
recommandation numéro 11 qui s'adresse à
la fois ministère mais également au
parlement c'est-à-dire à nous-mêmes
finalement qui consiste à établir à
titre exceptionnel la base législative
qui permettrait aux opérateurs des
systèmes de vidéoprotection dans les
espaces accessibles au public de mettre
en oeuvre des traitements d'image par
intelligence artificielle permettant le
comptage et la détection de mouvements
de foule on peut s'appuyer pour ce faire
sur un rapport qui vient d'être rendu il
ya quelques semaines par la commission
des lois par deux de nos collègues de la
commission qui traite ce sujet de
l'intelligence artificielle et notamment
de la reconnaissance faciale enfin le
rapport numéro 12 qui s'adresse au
préfet qui consiste à ce que le préfet
je vais fille la rédaction que j'ai pas
ce que je voudrais pas vous raconter des
blagues nous avons modifié la rédaction
pendant la commission et donc je ne fais
pas de bêtises voilà qui consiste à
imposer
au cas par cas je précise au cas par cas
aux opérateurs des systèmes de
vidéoprotection dans les espaces
accessibles au public à l'intérieur et
aux abords des équipements la
conservation des images captées le jour
des grands événements sportifs pendant
la durée légale d'un mois je précise au
cas par cas le droit commun reste les
délai de 30 jours bon ça c'est la loi et
la capacité pour les opérateurs de
garder moins longtemps le stade ces deux
jours vous connaissez tout ça mais le
préfet peut demander préalablement au
cas par cas la possible le fait de dire
vous conservez vos images par principe
30 jours ce qui permettrait de ne pas
subir ce que nous avons subi à savoir
l'incapacité de pouvoir avoir les images
notamment du grand stade mais également
d'autres opérateurs voilà merci de votre
attention j'ai sans doute été trop long
mais nous restons à votre disposition
il ya juste avant de vous donner la
parole de deux recommandations
complémentaires
sur la gestion des grands événements à
venir c'est tout à l'heure en préalable
et c'est extrêmement important à nos
yeux que ce qui s'est passé ne remet pas
en cause la capacité de la france à
organiser la coupe du monde et les jeux
olympiques et paralympiques mais
nécessite des décisions il y en a une
qui apparaît importante à nos yeux
concernant l'organisation des futurs
grands événements sportifs attendus dans
les années à venir on peut s'interroger
sur l'intérêt qu'une seule et même
personne soit à la fois dijon pop et djs
en effet plus nous nous rapprocherons de
la date du début des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques plus l'attention de la
délégation interministérielle aux jeux
olympiques et paralympiques devra être
mobilisés par cet événement exceptionnel
de par la taille le nombre de sites et
le nombre de d'événements sportifs or
avant et après les jeux olympiques serre
d'ici 2024 mais aussi sur des 2025 2026
des événements de taille importante
auront lieu en france il ne faut pas les
oublier et soûlé et non plus ne pas se
préparer à la bonne tenue de ces
événements a contrario nous avons
remarqué que l'organisation de la finale
de la ligue des champions 7 de france à
monterrey nous l'avons dit l'un et
l'autre un déficit de coordination entre
les différents acteurs concernés c'est
pourquoi nous proposons de mieux
distinguer les fonctions de délégué
interministériel aux grands événements
sportifs djs et de délégué
interministériel aux jeux olympiques et
paralympiques dijon afin de faire du djs
le responsable opérationnel et on
insiste sur ce thème opérationnel de
l'organisation des grands événements
sportifs internationaux hors jo et de
lui reconnaître un rôle de coordination
des différentes autorités concernées les
préfets y compris préfets départementaux
les forces de l'ordre les transports en
commun les fédérations sportives les
collectivités territoriales notamment
ces deux services mieux différencier
dans leurs attributions et leur rôle
auront vocation à interagir étroitement
pour partager le respect et leur
expertise respective
néanmoins il apparaît nécessaire qu'une
organisation dédiée puisse se concentrer
de manière opérationnelle tant sur les
grands événements sportifs prévus d'ici
2024 que sur ceux programmés entre 2024
et 2026 qui nécessitent le plus souvent
plusieurs années de préparation et ce
sera bien la djs de s'en occuper dans
notre esprit les commissions des lois et
de la culture du sénat organiseront dans
les mois à venir qui vit dans les mois
qui viennent par dont un suivi précis
des modalités de préparation des
prochains grands événements sportifs ou
regarder des enjeux de sécurité nous
avons d'ailleurs lancé une mission au
niveau de la commission culture de suivi
des jo au quel bien sûr sera étroitement
associée la commission des lois sur tous
les aspects de sécurité du public et par
ailleurs nous souhaitons que le
gouvernement remette au parlement un
rapport sur l'organisation de la
sécurité lors des grands événements
sportifs avant la fin de l'année 2022
voici toutes les propositions et le le
l'analyse que nous faisons des
recommandations j'ai oublié de préciser
mais j'en profite avant de donner la
parole
j'ai précisé au début que des autorités
de l'état ne s'était pas prononcé sur
les événements je poserai une question
au gouvernement tout à l'heure à 15h sur
ce sujet je me poserai bien sûr au nom
des deux commissions
voilà c'est de là
bonjour quand un calme est à public
sénat effectivement vous disiez les plus
hautes autorités de l'état ne se sont
pas exprimés en fait ce que vous
regrettiez c'était que la première
ministre où elle avance à jean castex
n'ait pas pris la parole exxon ou même
emmanuel macron enfin quel est
exactement le la critiques que vous
formulez vous n'aviez pas une commission
denquête c'était deux commissions
permanentes qui auditionnait donc a pas
eu de personnes auditionnées sous
serment en revanche est ce que vous
notez que malgré tout il ya des
personnes qui ont des témoignages qui ne
se recoupe avec d'autres escales et les
personnes dont le témoignage est et
posent questions notamment sur les
chiffres du nombre de supporters est ce
que la ratp par exemple donne des
chiffres qui vous pose question voilà où
est ce qu'à d'autres d'autres zones de
flou sur les témoignages et maintenant
dernier point c'est sur le préfet
l'allemand on entend que vous avez de
nombreuses qui voit la critique à
formuler à l'endroit de la préfecture de
police de paris il part dans une semaine
a priori selon le monde mais c'est
semble-t-il confirmez vous dites c'est
lié directement à ce qui s'est passé
autour du stade de france c'est y tient
la conclusion est en fait il démissionne
parce que là il est clairement pointée
du doigt ou est ce que vous dites que
c'est concomitants comment est ce que
vous voyez ce qui se passait autour de
ce départ
on va faire comme le faisons depuis le
début de ces auditions une réponse à
deux voies je commence le président
buffet continuera alors sur les plus
hautes autorités c'est clair il nous
semble que compte tenu de la gravité des
événements et ce contenu sur tout
l'enjeu pour la france de la préparation
d
jeux olympiques et paralympiques il est
nécessaire que le président ou la
première ministre s'exprime le fasse pas
à chaud ça peut se comprendre en
revanche maintenant nous sommes à plus
d'un mois et demi de l'événement je
crois qu'il est nécessaire qui est une
parole d'autorité qui apporte à la fois
la vision des plus hautes autorités de
ce qui s'est passé sur tous les
enseignements qu'ils en tirent sur les
témoignages contradictoires et les
chiffres de l'arrêté paix nous nous
prenons les chiffres tels qu'ils nous
ont été donnés ne sommes pas en capacité
de
2 les
de les tester de les approuver ou au
contraire de 2 de les contester mais
vous avez compris à travers la
présentation que que nous faisons et de
l'analyse des dysfonctionnements que
évidemment il y avait des supporteurs à
la vie des personnes en plus que les
80000 personnes qui sont rentrées dans
le stade mais comme l'a dit le président
de buffet on sait que il ya la capacité
de gérer cent dix mille personnes
concert indochine donc ce n'est pas
l'importance du nombre de gens présents
à proximité du stade qui est la cause
des dysfonctionnements là-dessus sommes
clairs sur le fait que c'est pas parce
que il y avait des supporters de
liverpool qui ont accompagné leur équipe
que ça s'est mal passé parce que
l'organisation n'avait pas anticipé le
fait qu'il était connu que les
supporters de liverpool se déplace en
masse même quand ils n'ont pas de quand
ils n'ont pas de deux billets voilà et
puis que dire d'autre que ce chiffre
nous prenons comme tel n'est pas enfin
nous n'avons pas les moyens de vérifier
donc sur le le préfet l'allemand sait
nous avons lu comme vous les nouveaux
bons articles annonçant
son
son départ attendant de voir si
l'information et est bien celle là nous
avons vous le savez auditionné le préfet
l'allemand est évident que dans la
chaîne de responsabilités il a sa part
de responsabilité elle est importante
surtout l'aspect maintien de l'ordre bon
fait quelques obsèques et quelques
recommandations sur la nécessité de
mieux coordonner en amont et pendant
l'événement sûr que
au moment de la finale de la champions
league en tout cas je trouve qu'il ya un
flou administratif
sur l'autorité hiérarchique qui devait
prendre les décisions il semble que ce
soit le préfet de police mais ce n'est
pas clairement énoncée par les uns et
les autres
oui notre commission denquête c'est vrai
parce que nous avons lancé des
opérations très rapidement mais malgré
tout les personnes que nous avons
auditionné
nous ont dit des choses de façon très
naturelle on n'a pas eu besoin de
d'autres moyens j'allais dire sur la
remise des pièces certains nous ont mis
des contributions écrites des éléments
donc il n'y a rien à redire là dessus en
revanche sur le fait de ce qui nous
manquera à tous jamais c'est des images
le vrai regret il est là ne manquera les
images il existe une partie des images
qui sont entre les mains sous main de
justice puisque finalement à la faveur
des auditions que nous avons menées et
mais le délai était de retard le
procureur de la république a enfin été
saisie pour conserver un certain nombre
d'image et maintenant elles sont sous
main de justice non pour nous ne sont
pas accessibles
légalement ils ne sont pas accessibles
c'est ce qui va nous manquer
singulièrement les images du stade c'est
ainsi mais ça ne remet pas cette absence
là pour le coup compte tenu de
l'ensemble des éléments qu'on a pu
obtenir ne remet pas en cause l'analyse
qui est faite et la mise en évidence des
dysfonctionnements qui ont été constatés
excusez moi
ni d'ailleurs pour atlantico
hormis les questions gouvernement et les
recommandations et les souhaits que vous
formulez quels moyens avez-vous pour
contraindre le président de la
république ou le premier ministre la
première ministre à s'exprimer à
s'expliquer
nous vous proposons c'est d'en prendre
plusieurs la plupart par contre appuyer
sur le bouton messieurs qu'on vous
entende bien
en fait ce que vous décrivez de façon à
la fois précise et pertinente c'est ce
qu'on avait plus ou moins confusément
perçu depuis depuis les événements
et vous vos propositions ci ajoute
évidemment ce qui est quand même
étonnant dans cette affaire c'est que
depuis depuis lors alors les pouvoirs
publics les représentants des pouvoirs
publics ont tardé à présenter les
excuses sens la vue mais c'est que sauf
erreur de ma part l'état et ses
représentants n'ont pas donné comme
de signes sur leurs capacités puisque en
gros ce qui est en cause c'est une
mauvaise perception des enjeux des
préjugés et c est surtout une mauvaise
organisation administrative et que
l'état n'a pas donné aucun signe à ce
jour de sa capacité dans la perspective
de ce qui nous attend de prendre les
dispositions qui s'imposent quoi ça vous
frappent pas ça je vais résoudre non non
c'est le changement de préfet n'a rien à
voir avec ça vous avez raison
[Musique]
les événements qui ont fall des autres
matchs qui ont eu lieu ensuite au sas 2
au stade de france se sont bien passées
et on a pu noter que malgré tout il
avait renforcé les services de police
les premières observations nous avions
fait il n'a été tenu compte mais cela
n'a jamais été exprimée publiquement
en fait c'est ce que vous dites
il serait utile je le crois parce que
il ne faut pas laisser
l'idée se répande comme quoi nous ne
serions pas en capacité d'organiser des
grands événements sportifs c'est pas
vrai chacun sait ici que notre pays est
capable d'organiser des galas
d'organiser des grands événements
c'était le cas avant et ce sera le cas
aujourd'hui et demain bien évidemment
donc ne laissons pas
cette idée là
perdurer et donc pour ce faire c'est
vrai qu'il serait utile à tout le moins
que le premier la première ministre dise
voilà on a entendu le rapport du sénat
on a entendu comme ça a été fait
récemment sur d'autres sujets on a
entendu tout ça on a mis bon ordre on se
réorganise ont fait et puis que les
choses soient dites et une fois qu'elle
se seront de dire lesquels seront dites
la situation sera clair est-ce qu'on a
des moyens de contrainte j'entendais la
mode question président la faune posera
une question d'actualité cet après midi
on a toujours la possibilité ensuite
deux convoqués devant la commission les
ministres compétents pour leur dire
alors vous en ai tout ça on peut
toujours le faire pourront peut-être
même qu'on le fera on l'a pas encore
décidé mais rien ne nous empêche comme
commission permanente et d'un trail
keynote de demander au ministre de venir
c'est ça nos moyens sont ceux ci ils ne
sont pas négligeables mais nos moyens
sont ceux ci pensent que c'est le cas il
est souhaitable nos points de vue une
expression publique ou plus haut niveau
de l'état notamment d'être au niveau de
matignon pour dire voilà on a pris les
choses en main on s'organise on a déjà
réagi et on prépare la suite ce serait à
mon avis rassurant pour tout le monde
mais notre rapport il est fait aussi
pour voir ce qu'ils vont en faire pour
l'instant la seule réponse de l'état
suite aux événements c'est le rapport
cadeaux avec un certain nombre de
recommandations mais c'est le rap rémy
par ledit job qui par ailleurs était
aussi acteur des événements donc on met
pas du tout en cause on a lu avec
attention et il ya des nombreuses
recommandations qui nous paraissent
intéressants dans le rapport
cadeau mais il nous semble que
effectivement pour toutes les raisons
qui évoquait le président buffet et
compte tenu de l'importance des jeux
olympiques il est indispensable que les
plus hautes autorités s'exprime pour
redonner confiance dans notre capacité à
organiser cjo personnellement nous n'en
doutons pas il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté
dans notre esprit nous n'en doutons pas
mais on sait que les événements du stade
de france sont forcément entraîner un
doute chez certains dans cette capacité
donc je pense qu'ils la voient et
l'autorité du premier ministre ou du
président de la république sont
nécessaires pour remettre dans le droit
chemin tous les organisateurs de deux
des grands événements à venir monsieur
oui vous dites vous n'en doutez pas mais
étant donné le nombre de recommandations
que vous fournissez aujourd'hui ce qui
n'a pas tout de même un doute vu le
temps qui reste pour organiser les
principaux événements et principalement
la france est capable d'organiser des
événements de ce type mais en cas de
crise précisément on voit qu'elle est
dans une difficulté à faire communiquer
tous les acteurs nécessaires et c'est ce
qu'on a bien vu pendant les éditions
c'est une coproduction il ya une
mauvaise communication les
recommandations qui ont fait que l'on
fait par ton sont des recommandations
qui nécessite pas d'intervention
l'initiative à l'exception d'une et tout
le reste c'est de l'organisation c'est
du management c'est donc c'est des
choses qui peut être très rapide à
mettre en place à partir de mon partage
le constat est on est d'accord avec les
recommandations
c'est de la mise en oeuvre pour ça il
n'y a pas besoin de délai extraordinaire
si vous interrogez une entreprise privée
qui a besoin de s'organiser veut le
faire très vite il ya pas de raison
qu'on n'y arrive pas quand même pas que
le gouvernement n'y arrive pas et que la
migration n'arrivent pas à se mettre en
ordre de marche en tous les cas il faut
le souhaiter sinon effectivement
s'inquiétant de la raison madame j'ai
peut-être été imprécis nous n'en doutons
pas si des décisions sont prises
et à ce stade je crois que la première
ministre a dit qu'elle prenait le
rapport cadeaux dans sa globalité tant
mieux mais ça nécessite quand même
semble-t-il des réponses un peu plus
précise et appropriée serait vraiment
les décisions encore une fois elles sont
dans l'administratif qui seront prises
pour éviter que ces événements se
reproduisent madame
voilà deux questions la première c'était
pour avoir des précisions concernant la
difficulté en tout cas le fait que vous
ayez pas pu avoir copie des images de
vidéosurveillance notamment de la pp ou
encore je vois de la ville de
saint-denis puisqu'en fait il ya pas eu
de réponse du procureur dont je voulais
juste avoir des précisions à ce que vous
savez à quel moment
l'enquète ce serait ouverte et donc
qu'elle soit sous saisie je dirais pas
non mais pour comprendre comment ça se
fait que vous ayez pas eu une copie que
le même la préfecture au ministère de
l'intérieur n'ait pas estimé utile dans
le cadre de cette commission dans le cas
de enfin pour l'intérêt général de vous
en fournir une copie c'est un point qui
m'interpelle et la deuxième question que
j'aimerais vous poser c'est en fait il
ya eu évidemment les images de chaos qui
ont terni l'image de la france et à
l'étranger mais ce qui a été relevé
également à l'étranger comme en france
et les mensonges qui sont suivies je
pense aux mensonges du préfet repris par
le ministre de l'intérieur monsieur
darmanin et là dessus alors je sais pas
si ça peut donner lieu à une
recommandation à une question
gouvernement mais je vous vois pas trop
insistant sur aussi l'effet dévastateur
qu'on peut avoir ces mensonges qui ont
perduré quand même assez longtemps avant
qui est certain regret par rapport à ce
qui s'est passé la recommandation quête
permanente c'est de dire la vérité
mais c'est une orientation qui n'ont
même pas besoin des deux fêtes c'est
paraît tellement naturel donc mais on
peut leur dire oralement oui la
recommandation c'est de dire la vérité
quand un événement de cette nature parce
que si la vérité avait été dite tout de
suite
immédiatement on ne serait pas là deux
mois après à se retrouver à faire un
rapport avoir un mythe ce système aurait
été constatés et les choses auraient été
réglées peut être rapidement tous les
cas on l'espère mais je vous pensais pas
que ça nécessite peut-être justement que
ce soit des parlementaires des sénateurs
qui leur rappellent que le demande et
que ce soit publiquement nous tenons
c'est ce que nous faisons depuis
quelques semaines parce qu'on
intervenants comme nous l'avons fait
dans un souci de transparence en dans
toutes ses auditions publiques c'est
aussi une interpellation que nous
faisons
vernon également de répondre et quand on
dit qu'il est nécessaire à ce stade que
les plus hautes autorités de l'état
s'exprime c'est aussi pour donner une
parole
plus juste que celle que nous avons
entendus jusqu'à présent messieurs on va
prendre plusieurs questions si vous en
êtes d'accord
on prend plusieurs questions peut-être
comme ça chacun pourra se créer monsieur
oui merci le sénateur mc symbian agit de
la revue parlementaire
on a parlé des mensonges un instant
si je comprends bien la responsable des
responsabilités
ils ont marqué par jardin mana des
supporters anglais dont les événements
après les auditions des deux
responsables de clubs de supporteurs
anglais de liverpool vous nous confirmez
donc que bon il s'agissait bien d'un
mensonge de la part du miz l'intérieur
la question est volontairement
et volontairement direct mais malgré
tout il ya eu un tweet
immédiatement le soir même des
événements puis il a confirmé sa
première version
donc bon manifestement les responsables
et les supporters anglais si j'en crois
le rapport ne sont en rien responsables
de ce qui s'est passé
notre plaisir si vous voulez bien mais
on va voir un
tel cas loi de l'agencé espagnole de
presse est fait pour inciter sur la même
question pourquoi ne demandez vous pas
de responsabilité à ce niveau là a dit
manière directe est ce que ça ne serait
pas une manière de répondre aussi aux
pour ma lettre d des aficionados qui qui
se sont sentis en paix berné et qu'est
ce que vous pouvez dire en tout cas à ce
sujet pour ces pour ses supporteurs qui
étaient là qui est un qui ont souffert
là la mauvaise préparation
j'ai une question un petit peu en lien
avec ce qui vient d'être dit vous avez
fait plusieurs recommandations il ya
aucune recommandation de sanctions
vis-à-vis des acteurs parce que nous
avons à pointer les responsables des uns
des autres mais vous n'avait demandé
aucune sanction contre les responsables
pourquoi
moi je vais revenir sur les images de
vidéosurveillance lors de votre point le
16 juin au stade de france vous aviez
dit que vous alliez saisir la justice
pour les obtenir qu'en est il
on pourrait imaginer qu'un ministre
démissionne pour des faits encore moins
grave que ce que nous avons vécu en
france la cepalc à ou kid et met enfin
ou qu'il fasse muté comme on dit entre
guillemets le préfet en l'occurrence
rien n'a été fait donc qu'est-ce que ça
aussi ça aurait pu faire partie de
questions au gouvernement ou alors de
recommandation
bon je préviens du fait d'une demande
gentiment de commencer
mais nous allons faire
bon d'abord par rapport aux supporteurs
de liverpool et aussi de du real de
madrid évidemment nous nous avons nous
l'avons fait à plusieurs reprises
refaisons un présentons nos excuses nos
regrets et nos excuses par rapport à ce
qui s'est passé c'est pour ça que
c'était extrêmement important à nos yeux
et à l'ensemble des membres des deux
commissions qu'ils soient entendus et
qu'il s'exprime sur ce qu'ils ont vécu
au delà de
2 du fait qu'ils aient vraiment été
victime on ne dit peut-être pas assez
mais derrière ces événements il ya aussi
un enjeu diplomatique singulièrement par
rapport à l'angleterre nos compétences
mais dans l'expression nécessaire d du
président de la république du premier
ministre je crois qu'ils doivent aussi
intégrer c'est cette dimension là il
sent que c'est important qui est des
mots qu'ils soient adressés à aux
spectateurs et aux autorités de ces deux
peuples amis de ces deux pays amis
parlent
bon pourquoi ne pas demander de
sanctions ce n'est pas notre rôle
restons dans notre rôle nous sommes dans
un rôle de contrôle qui nous est donnée
par la constitution d'établir des faits
de comprendre des dysfonctionnements
d'essayer d'identifier des
responsabilités évidemment peut-être que
sur certains aspects de notre analyse
nous ne sommes pas allés assez loin où
il ya une nécessité de mettre en oeuvre
des procédures contradictoires pour que
ceux qui sont
pointés dans le rapport puisse se
justifier ça dépasse notre rôle
évidemment nous resterons dans le cadre
de nos missions et si des sanctions
doivent être prises c'est aux
responsables et aux autorités et rachid
des personnes responsables que
de le faire
sur gérald darmanin de sa responsabilité
et de son expression je pense que nous
le montrons clairement
ce matin et dans le rapport écrit que
nous avons tenu à faire est extrêmement
important que nous finissions notre nos
travaux par un document écrit qui met
noir sur blanc un certain nombre de
choses et qu'ils fassent des
propositions encore une fois votée à
l'unanimité
dd2 que commission bon il est très clair
que les deux arguments qui ont été mis
en avant par le ministre de l'intérieur
dès le samedi soir et le dimanche à
savoir que les troubles occasionnés et
les dysfonctionnements occasionné les
incidents constatés étaient liés à un
afflux massif de spectateurs et à une
présence
fausses billetteries importante ces deux
arguments existent mais ce ne sont pas
la cause des dysfonctionnements les
dysfonctionnements on la présentait avec
précision et
vous vous les avez bien sûr à l'esprit
on voit bien que l'analyse
de deux faite par le ministre de
l'intérieur le soir du match et le
lendemain du match n'était pas la bonne
c'était une analyse partielle et
imprécises qui n'a pas permis dès le
soir du match et ayral dans
l'immédiateté de prendre un peu de
hauteur de vue et d'engager l'état à
faire
apporter tous les éléments nécessaires à
la compréhension
de ce point de vue là les propos du
ministre de l'intérieur n'était pas à la
hauteur des incidents constatés et de
l'émotion suscitée par ces incidents
après ce qui est important de distinguer
et à l'aspect communication après
l'événement je viens de dire bon il ya
tout l'aspect gestion de l'événement en
préparation comme en exécution
là dessus il est clair que ce n'est pas
aux le ministre de l'intérieur pas plus
que ce n'est celui du sport qui étaient
en première ligne ce sont les différents
acteurs que vous connaissez je reviens
pas qui était en responsabilité et ce
qui s'est passé le jour du match
c'est ce défaut de préparation ces
imprécisions dans la préparation qu'ils
ont et l'exécution le jour même qui en
sont la cause
je crois que c'est important ce qui
vient de ce que vient de dire laurent
lafon le rôle d'une commission d'une
mission comme la nôtre n'est pas de
demander c'est vrai pour nous c'est vrai
pour les autres de demander la démission
d'untel ou d'untel de l'exécutif on
n'est pas ou de n'importe quelle
organisation d'ailleurs
c'est pal usage en exil face d'avoir ses
paysages c'est pas la règle je pense
quand même qu'on n'aurait pas le bon on
dépasserait notre propre mission ça veut
pas dire qu ensuite sur la base du
document dans le débat public ce
document ne soit pas saisie dans le
débat public chacun fera baisse qui
voudra eric hamas qui voudra mais c'est
pas dans le rapport que l'on peut dire
on veut la démission d'untel ou d'untel
donc c'est pas le seul cas possible mais
c'est hors sujet circonstance et en cas
de commission enquête une infraction
pénale été constaté auquel cas dans un
processus qui est parfaitement établie
interne à la maison ont saisi le
président de l'assemblée qui lui-même
saisi banques la pluie qu'on est dans
autre chose on en n'est pas là donc
c'est pas ça le sud donc on ne fait pas
ça et on ne le fera pas en revanche on
décrit objectivement tous les cas nous
le pensons est rigoureusement nous le
pensons aussi la situation les faits
tels qu'ils se sont passées de façon à
ce qu'on essaye de comprendre pourquoi
ça n'a pas fonctionné je crois qu'on est
à peu près arrivé mais arrivait
correctement le reste ne nous appartient
pas et chacun assumera sa responsabilité
comme ils le souhaitent en revanche
sur la notion qu évoqué laurent lafon du
mensonge d'euskadi untel ou untel
on note en tous les cas que les
positions ont évolué au fur et à mesure
que les auditions ont eu lieu et que nos
commissions en connaissance de la
situation et ont pu établir en réalité
que les premières déclarations
correspond n'est pas la vérité oui c'est
exact et on l'écrit et en assume de
lettres de l'écrire ce qui a été dit
dans les premières heures ne correspond
pas à la réalité de ce qui s'est passé
voilà
ton pacte mais je crois que là-dessus on
a essayé de tenir la spécialité pour le
coup qu'est la nôtre qui est de décrire
les choses telles qu'elles se sont
passées pas qu'on aurait imaginé qu'elle
se passe et rentables qu'elles se sont
passées
voilà
vous souhaiter bon appétit non
parce que nous on n'a pas mangé
aujourd'hui
voilà bonnette merci à vous merci à la
maladière
micro micro les images animées image et
sur les images
rappelez-moi précisément ce que vous
avez dit je suis et plus
j'avais oublié nous présentait donc ces
régimes d'alfort de ses news et je vous
avais dit que lors du 16 juin l'art de
vote pré sable en point vous aviez dit
que vous allez faire
des sites effectivement d'évasion on a
demandé via le ministère de la justice
d'obtenir
l'autorisation de teint l'autorisation
du procureur de la république de pouvoir
nous donner accès à ces images et on
nous a fait savoir que ça n'était pas
possible et que dès lors que les images
étaient sous main de justice elle ne
pouvait pas être mise à disposition à
notre disposition dont acte je pense que
ce port joli que ça tient à peu près
mais bon on a tenté quand même
merci à vous bonne bonne fin du rebond
de l'après midi en fin de journée sera
encore